PAUL SAXMAN: Welcome, everybody,
to our talk on
building second screen apps that
integrate with Google TV.
My name is Paul Saxman, and
I'm a senior developer
advocate at Google on
the Google TV team.
And with me today is--
DAVE FISHER: I'm Dave Fisher.
I'm actually a faculty member.
I work at a college in Indiana,
and I'm on my
sabbatical.
I've been working at Google
for the last year or so.
And in the fall, I'm going
to go back to teaching.
PAUL SAXMAN: Cool.
So Paul Saxman, Dr. Fisher.
And if you guys want to follow
along today, we got the Go
link up on the top there to
actually get to the slides.
They're going to stay there
indefinitely, too, so if you
want to check them out
afterwards, you can
go check them out.
So you're all probably familiar
with this type of
TV-viewing experience here.
For the sake of this
conversation, we're going to
call him Mr. Leanback.
I can see some of you today are
kind of in the leanback
mode as well, probably because
it's second day, Google I/O,
you guys had your lunch.
So this is a fairly common
TV-viewing kind of
arrangement.
And so Mr. Leanback, let's say
he comes home from a long day
at work, or he's been outside
with activities.
And so he grabs his favorite
beverage, he grabs his remote
control, and then he goes into
what we call the leanback
mode, which is approximately
45 degree from the floor.
If you're any more than 45 or
any less than a 45-degree
angle from the floor, you're
no longer in leanback mode.
That's laydown mode.
And we're not going to talk
about laydown mode today.
So the thing about the leanback
mode or what Mr.
Leanback, the way he's watching
TV, is that this is a
fairly common way to
watch television.
This is exactly why, when we
talk about developing apps for
Google TV, we give you UI
guidelines about kind of
toning down the user
interface.
Put less information.
Make the interface a
lot easier to use.
Support D-pad navigation,
because obviously Mr. Leanback
is not going to want to put
his drink down to use the
remote two-handed.
And this is also why, when we
designed Google TV, we put
apps on there, or we provided
services like Quick Search and
the TV and Movies application,
which allows users to actually
really quickly and easily
get access to content.
Because they don't necessarily
need the overload of
navigating through a list of
200+ channels to find what
they want to watch.
They can just search for it or
actually launch the app and
browse for it.
However, there's a lot of data
coming out recently that
actually paints a slightly
different picture of the way
that we interact with TVs.
This is something
from Nielsen.
It was actually just published
the end of last year.
And they found that about
90% of tablet owners and
smartphone owners actually use
their devices while watching
television.
And the way they did this
actually, they broke it down
into how often they
use their device.
They said, do they do it
monthly, daily, weekly,
multiple times daily.
And it was actually heavily
skewed towards daily usage.
So most users, 90% of users or
more, actually use their
devices while they're
watching TV.
And I'm sure that's probably
the same with most of us.
So the other interesting thing,
too, about smartphones
now, is that as more people have
smartphones and tablet
devices, they're actually
designed for pushing
information to the user as
opposed to, let's say, other
devices like computers or
laptops, where's it's more,
the user actually is driving.
So smartphones, for example, if
you're watching a movie and
you get a text message that
comes in, or you go a Google
Talk, or you get an email that
comes in, you're more likely
nowadays to pick up your phone
and start interacting with it
while you're watching TV.
So this whole idea of like
multi-screen or second screen
interaction is kind of new and
very much on the rise.
So we actually conducted
a study, very recently.
This was at the beginning
of this year.
And we surveyed people that
actually have and actively use
Google TV devices.
And asked them, do you have
certain devices, other
connected devices
in your home?
So we found that actually 92%
of these homes have laptops.
And a very large number, 90%,
also have smartphones.
And actually, the large majority
of them also have
desktop and tablet computers
as well.
So we see there's actually
quite a few--
given this data, with the data
in the previous slide, we can
see that the probability of
somebody actually having and
using a second screen device
in their living room while
they're watching TV is actually
very, very high.
I mean, it's well into the
majority of people.
So there's actually--
what you may think of now
is this situation here.
We're going to call her
Ms. Multi-screen.
So not only does Ms.
Multi-screen have her snack
and her remote control, but also
now in the living room,
she has her laptop
and smartphone.
And most likely, actually, has
a tablet computer as well.
And this whole idea of like
kind of multi-screen
interaction, or actually, what
we'll call just multitasking,
for lack of a better word, is
that this isn't a new idea.
I mean, people have been doing
this for quite a few years.
Just a few years back, instead
of a smartphone, she probably
had a feature phone.
Or even a few years before that,
she might have had a
cordless phone.
Or maybe if you're like my
family, you might have had a
corded phone, but you had one of
those 20-foot curly cables
on there that was kind of
stretched out, just so that
you could sit in the living
room while you were
talking on the phone.
And so the interesting thing
about this, though, is that
really, portable devices
are really on the rise.
So smartphones are
on the rise.
We see that laptop computer
usage, people are
transitioning from desktop
computers to laptop computers.
So really, this scenario of kind
of the multi-screen or
multi-devices in the living
room is pretty much here.
So in the same study that we
conducted before about what
percentage of users actually
have other devices, we also
asked them how many
devices they have.
And we found some pretty
interesting numbers.
On average, they have
about two laptops.
Which is pretty surprising,
because most of these homes,
they're about two and a
half to three people.
So you can say that either most
of the adults in the home
or most people in the home
actually have access to a
laptop computer.
Same thing with smartphones.
Desktops and tablets, these are
actually one per home, on
average, for people
that actively
use Google TV devices.
And we actually found that
there's a median of six
connected devices
in these homes.
And when I first read that,
I was kind of shocked.
I was like, six devices
connected in the living room--
or not just in the living room,
but in their homes--
is pretty high.
But when I started to count all
the connected devices that
I have my home, it ended up
a lot higher than 12.
Or, a lot higher than 6.
It was actually around 12 to 15,
depending on if I had my
work computer at home
or not, or my work
devices at home as well.
So yeah.
There's a number of connected
devices that people can use to
connect to their TVs.
And this number, this median
number of six, it doesn't just
include smartphones and
tablets, desktops, and
laptops, but it also includes
things like set-top boxes,
media devices, and that
type of thing.
So I challenge you to actually
count the number of connected
devices you have
in your homes.
I think you've probably got
about four of them here at
Google I/O, so you can add
those to your number.
And you'll probably come
out to a pretty
astronomical number.
So given all these numbers that
I've presented, this is
kind of maybe a slightly more
typical arrangement for being
in the living room.
I mean Ms. Multi-screen was a
little bit of an exaggeration.
We're going to call this
Team More Typical.
And what we kind of expect to
see in the living room these
days is that--
you have to remember that the
TV-viewing experience is a
social experience.
So chances are there's probably
multiple people in there.
It's not always the case where
people are having a shared
TV-viewing experience, but
it commonly is the case.
You can definitely expect
that there's one or
more laptops available.
For a group this size, there's
probably a couple.
People don't always take their
laptops over to their friend's
house if they're going to watch
a TV show, but that
certainly does happen if they're
maybe doing some study
work, and then they're
switching over
to watching TV later.
Or, if you're like me, when I
was in school, watching TV and
using the computer at the
same time, which my
parents always hated.
But you also kind of expect that
people have at least one
tablet per household, for people
that are Google TV
users and owners.
And for a group this size,
probably approximately three
smartphones.
So there's a number of
different types of
configurations, a number of
different ways of people can
use devices to interact
with the TV.
So really, the opportunity for
developers like yourselves is
that people really want to do
more than just watch TV.
I mean, they really want to
start interacting with TV.
And the way they can interact
with the TV is they can use
their physical remote control,
which nowadays,
they're pretty elaborate.
They have keyboards on them.
They have D-pads.
Some of them have touchpads
or gyroscopic sensors.
Or you can actually give them
the ability to actually use
their devices that they have
and that they're using in
their homes to actually
interact with the TV.
So start thinking about how
you'd use their smartphones,
their tablets, their
laptop computers.
A number of different things
they can do to interact with
TV nowadays.
The other thing is that you can
also take advantage of the
fact that both of
these markets--
the Smart TV market and the
second screen, or let's say,
the handheld portable device
markets-- are actually very,
very much on the rise.
As we heard yesterday, there's
I think 400 million Android
activations now.
That's a million activations
a day.
So the number of people that
actually have access to second
screen devices in the home is
constantly going up and is
going up at a pretty
rapid rate.
And the other thing
is that Smart TVs
are also on the rise.
It's projected that by about
2015, there's going to be 500
million LCD TVs that have
shipped with internet
connectivity.
And that is just LCD TVs that
are shipped with connectivity.
It doesn't include devices that
actually are connected to
the internet with a set-top
box or another device.
So the number of Smart TV
devices or connected-TV
devices on the market in the
next few years are definitely
going up, so this is definitely
a great time to
take advantage of this
kind of arrangement.
So to kind of pique your
creativity, I'll give you a
few examples of developers
that are building second
screen apps now, or applications
that are second
screen apps.
For example, this one here,
this is the Able remote.
The developer of Able remote,
he took the Google TV remote
control application
that we launched
open-source last year.
He added a number of really,
really great features.
It still actually is a universal
remote control.
It has all universal remote
control functionality, like
the original application.
But he added things like you
can favorite channels and
actually quickly change channels
using the device.
So if you're like me, you have
200 channels, but you really
only watch about 5.
This makes it kind of brainless
to actually get to
your favorite shows.
He has the same functionality
with applications and
websites, as well.
So if you have a favorite
application on the device, if
you have a favorite website on
the device, you can actually
get to it in just a few clicks
on your handheld device.
And then he also built in some
really interesting integration
with Google Music.
It's a widget on your handheld
device that can actually
control the playback
on Google Music.
The Peel Smart Remote app--
they're actually in the Sandbox
today, so if you
haven't had a chance to
see their application,
now's a good time.
The Peel Smart Remote app is a
TV and movies discovery app
with some ties into
social ties.
So the integration, the way that
it integrates with Google
TV, like the Able remote, they
actually give you the ability
to control your TV with
your handheld device.
So if you've actually launched
into a VOD service on Google
TV, like Netflix, you actually
can get play controls.
And you can actually can get
navigation controls as well.
So if you're in the application,
you can navigate
around, get more information
about
the show you're watching.
You can actually navigate out of
the application as well and
use the Peel app to navigate
the Google TV interface.
On the left-hand side, this
is actually their phone
application.
On the right-hand side is
the tablet version.
Trivialist is actually a
little bit different.
So Trivialist is not a remote
control application.
So on the right-hand side is
actually the TV application.
So what they've done is
they've built a trivia
application.
They're putting that on Google
TV devices and then putting
those Google TV devices
in sports bars.
You go into a sports bar.
If you don't already have the
Trivialist app, you can see
that you have the opportunity
to download it.
You put it on your smartphone,
and then you can actually play
trivia with other people
at the sports bar.
The interesting thing about
this application on the
technological side is that
they're not actually
communicating from the
handheld device to
the Google TV device.
They're actually using
the cloud.
So any command, or when you make
decisions on the phone,
it actually sends
it up the cloud.
And when it's time to change the
question, actually that's
being pushed down to
your phone as well.
So the communication's
not direct.
And obviously, the reason for
that is that not all sports
bars have open networks, so
you can't really rely on
phone-to-device or phone-to-TV
communication directly.
And last but not least, MOVL.
MOVL actually was at Google
I/O last year with us.
They're also at Google I/O
with us this year.
I think they're in the
Google TV Lounge now.
So they actually have Android
and web-based multi-screen
applications and APIs that
integrate with Google TV.
The applications that--
on the right-hand side here,
this is the Poker Fun game,
which is really cool.
You can play poker with multiple
of your friends in
your living room,
or actually--
I think it actually works now
with people in other living
rooms as well.
And you have your personal
experience on your handheld
device, and the TV actually has
a shared experience, which
is the poker table.
They have WeDraw and
WeTeli as well.
These work with their APIs,
the Cloud Connect and the
Direct Connect platforms or
APIS, for both cloud-based and
direct communication with
the Google TV device.
And they also have what they
call the Kontrol TV platform
or the controller, which
actually puts all the apps
into one handheld control.
So the goal for us today, so
now that you hopefully are
kind of inspired to build second
screen apps, we're
going to teach you what you need
to know to start building
these applications.
And to do that, we're first
going to teach you how to
share data, basically share
any data, between a second
screen and a first
screen device.
Then we're going to talk a
little bit about the Anymote
Protocol and Library for
sending input events--
input events specifically--
from the second screen to the
first screen or to Google TV.
And then we're going to show you
how to implement a Chrome
extension using Anymote
for actually
controlling Google TV.
And that's Dave's specialty.
So on to the technical
side of things.
So like I said, I'm going to
tell you how to share any data
between second screen
and first screen
or Google TV devices.
And to do that, I'm going to
do a quick demo to kind of
show you what I mean.
This demo, what we did is we put
together a few demos for
using sensor information.
So the handheld device actually
becomes kind of a
sensor proxy for the TV.
So what we'll do is we're going
to bring up the sensor
application on the TV.
These are just demos.
I mean, they're very simple
applications.
But hopefully it'll kind of
give you an idea of what's
possible when you can just
basically pass any data
between the two devices.
So this is called the
remote sensor data.
So basically, we took some of
the sensor demos that we had
for Android, and we ported
them to Google TV.
This is actually the ColorCube
Cube example that you can get
for your Android devices.
And so what I'm going to do now
is I'm going to pair my
handheld device with
the Google TV.
This pairing--
it's a little bit dark, but
I hope you can see it.
So the pairing process
can be automatic.
There's technologies that
can make it automatic.
Let's see if I'm
paired already.
Nope.
Find Google TVs.
So what I'm going to do is--
since we don't have auto-pairing
on this network,
I'm actually just going
to enter the IP
address real quick.
And this is kind of a one-time
process, because next time I
try to connect, it should
automatically be there.
And we conveniently put the IP
address on the display so that
you can quickly launch this.
So now I'm going to--
on the phone, I'm going
to launch the
Colored Cube interface.
You probably recognize this from
Android phones as one of
the Android samples.
And what we're doing now is
basically, the handheld device
has become a proxy.
So any of the sensor commands
on the handheld device are
just sent directly across
to the television.
So if I pick this
up, you won't be
able to see it anymore.
But as I rotate the
phone around, it
actually rotates the cube.
And the first time I actually
ran this demo, I was little
bit confused, because as I
rotate the phone, let's say,
to the left, actually, the cube
rotates to the right.
It doesn't seem-- it seems
like the perspective's a
little bit backwards.
But what it's actually doing is
on the phone, since you're
looking into the screen, when
you rotate the handheld
device, you're actually kind of
rotating your perspective
of the cube.
And we actually maintain that
type of perspective.
But you'd actually think when
I rotate the phone down, you
might want to rotate
the cube down.
Just a caveat if you try
to do this yourself.
I'll give one more quick demo,
and then we'll move on.
We also took the Sensor
Graph demo.
And let's see if I
can click that.
So this is also one of
the Android examples.
We also ported it to TV.
And this is kind of to show that
we're taking pretty much
the main sensors--
I think we're taking the
accelerometer, the gyroscope,
and the orientation sensors--
and we're just actually passing
all that information
to the TV and rendering
it here.
So you see, if I pick up the
phone, if I start to rotate
it, move it around--
all that information
is being sent
back, pretty much real-time.
We haven't necessarily
benchmarked it, because a lot
of it depends really on the
nature of the network.
But with the technology we're
using, I mean, it's really
low-level UDP communication, you
can pretty much guarantee
it's real-time communication.
And actually, as the phone goes
to sleep, it actually
sends the disconnect command.
So that's why we just saw
it go away there.
So now we'll talk a little bit
of how you can actually
implement something like
that on Google TV.
So back to the slides--
oh, thanks Dave.
OK, we've got the demo.
So this is the do-it-yourself
version, so if you wanted to
actually build pretty
much that same
application from scratch.
Like I said, Google TV devices
all broadcast using mDNS, and
Anymote TCP local service.
So if you want to find Google TV
devices on somebody's home
network, all you really do
is you search for this
_anymote._tcp.local
by using mDNS.
Once you actually find it, you
can actually extract out the
name of the device, the IP
address, and the port.
The port is actually for the
Anymote service, which we'll
talk about a little bit later.
But this is actually a quick and
easy way to actually get
access to the device or find
devices on the network.
So the example code here,
this is actually
using the JmDNS library.
I would highly recommend
that you use the
library to do this.
Otherwise, you'd actually have
to build an mDNS client from
scratch, which could be a lot of
fun, but it could also be a
lot of work.
So starting a service on a
device in Android world, or in
Java in general, you can rely
on the java.net libraries.
It's fairly straightforward to
open up a server socket, bind
it to a port, and actually
start communication.
So here, we have an example.
We're starting the server
socket on port 1337.
We have a loop here, because
what ends up happening is you
block for communication.
Once the connection is
made, you unblock.
Once the socket is closed, or
you finish your communication,
then you can go back to a reset
state, so you're waiting
for communication again.
So like I said, the opening of a
socket that blocks until the
communication accepted.
And then you have to implement
a couple of methods for
reading data and writing
data from the
input and output streams.
Likewise, to connect to the
service using the java.net
libraries is very
straightforward.
You open up your socket.
You pass it the IP address
and the port.
You write and read your data.
Writing and reading data, you're
streaming data back and
forth using the input
and output ports.
You close your socket.
When you actually-- if you
want to port this to an
Android application and
productize it, though, things
get a lot more--
we'll say serious.
So when you open up the socket
communication, the port may
already be used.
Don't take this slide
too seriously.
I actually went through and
tried this, built this
application out from scratch
using the sensor APIs.
So these are actually real
to-dos, but we'll get to the
point of why I put this slide
up here in a minute.
But you have to worry
about things--
is the port already used?
How do you handle
the exceptions?
Because there's a lot of
exceptions that can be thrown
at various places.
With Android, you can't do any
network on the UI thread, so
you obviously have to
spawn off threads.
And in this situation, you
probably want to spawn off a
couple of threads.
One thread to actually do the
network off of the UI thread
and another thread to actually
do I/O so that you can open up
your communication for a second
device to communicate
at the same time.
Because they both use
the same socket.
And a little bit more.
So the another really important
thing to remember is
that reading and
writing data--
if you want to read and write
structured data, you need some
way to actually serialize and
deserialize that data.
And that actually has to be
the same on both sides.
You have to have kind of a
mirroring of the serialization
and deserialization.
So if you're using one
technology to serialize the
data on the handheld device,
you need to use the same
technology or similar technology
to deserialize it.
Likewise with actually opening
up the socket connection.
When you port this to a
production Android device,
there's a lot more work that
needs to go into it.
The biggest one is actually,
sometimes mDNS doesn't work.
For example, a lot of corporate
networks, they block mDNS.
Most users' home networks
don't, however.
But you may want to give the
user the ability to enter an
IP address.
This requires you to open
up a dialogue or some
type of user interface.
You have to start the threads,
et cetera, to actually do the
communication.
So there's a lot more work.
Socket communication
is a lot of fun.
Like I said, I went through
building an application from
scratch that does everything
in socket communication.
I had something that was
reasonably well working after
a couple hundred
lines of code.
When I started to put a little
bit more of the Android
framework in there about the UI
to allow people to actually
manually enter, I was up to
maybe about 500 lines of code.
It took me a couple of days
to actually get it in good
working order.
So to kind of help developers
not have to go through that,
all of you to go through that
every time, what we've done is
we've put together a Google TV
Data Sharing Android Library
for Android developers.
We're in the process of
launching this now.
It's not quite out there, but
it will be out there in a
couple days.
We're waiting for one last
approval from open sourcing.
So what the Google TV Data
Sharing Library does is it
really simplifies for Android
developers the process of
finding and sharing data
with Google TV.
It's built on a client/server
infrastructure or
architecture.
And both libraries are actually
in one package.
And they actually work
almost the same way.
So actually, I'll go over a
little bit the code, but the
code works on both sides
relatively the same way.
So the library actually deals
with things like the service
discovery and pairing.
It includes the UI.
The library's open source, so
if you don't like the UI the
way it is, you can obviously
tweak it.
It deals with the socket
communication, and that
includes the threading and
the exception handling.
That also deals with the
data serialization and
deserialization using protocol
buffers, which is a really
lightweight and
language-agnostic protocol for
deserializing and serializing
data.
It's part of the way that we
actually get the really
low-latency communication.
And in this library, we baked
in a few things, like the
reference messages, which
include registration.
That tells you when the device
connected, disconnected, and
pinging the device.
Sensor data, so the sensor demo
that I gave you, we have
the protocol buffers in there
for sending sensor data.
And it's not the entire suite,
because it seems like there's
a new sensor almost every day
with Android, but we got most
of the main ones.
And if your favorite sensor's
not in there, you're
absolutely free to
add it in there.
And generic data, that's
basically just strings.
So if you have serialized data
on your second screen device
and you want to send, for
example, JSON or XML, and you
want to send that your first
screen device, you can
actually just package it into a
string, send it across, and
actually deserialize your JSON
or XML or whatever your
favorite string-based data
serialization format is.
So really, implementing this
is pretty straightforward.
And this is actually going to
be a lot of code in the next
few sections.
This was an advanced course,
so hopefully you're waiting
for a little bit of code.
So you actually implement this
CallbackListener, just two
simple methods, one for dealing
with errors and one
for dealing with the
data coming back.
Oh, and by the way,
don't worry about
copying all this down.
This is all going to go out in
our documentation, so it's
mostly cut-and-paste.
And I think most of it's
actually in an activity that
you can implement or extend
yourself, what we'll call the
data-sharing activity, which
will simplify things.
But if you wanted to use this
code the most flexible way,
you want to implement
this activity.
So you want to implement a
service connection so that you
can attach your
CallbackListener, which was
your activity, to the
data-sharing client.
And that's basically this
line right here.
So once the service is
connected, the service is
actually what does the
communication, which you don't
have to implement.
But once the service is
connected, you attach your
ClientListener to the data
service, and that's how you
get these callbacks on error
and response data.
And likewise, when the service
is disconnected, you want to
shut things down so you're no
longer listening for results.
And then you start the service,
and this actually
gets things going.
So this actually kicks off the
pairing process, which
includes things like
the user interface
for doing the pairing.
It does the whole mDNS scanning
the network as well,
and will give the user interface
if there's multiple
devices on the network.
So that's pretty much it.
And from that point on, it's
just a matter of actually
sending your messages
and your code.
So protocol buffers, the way
it works is you take a
protocol buffer definition, you
convert that into a Java
class, if you're programming
Java.
But it is language-agnostic,
so you can basically turn
protocol buffer definition
into pretty much any
programming language interface
implementation.
But you create your protocol
buffer, you add your data to
the protocol buffer message,
and then you just ship it,
which is the last line here.
So one last thing.
So this is actually what the
protocol buffer looks like.
And for the sensor data, we
actually made the protocol
buffer look almost exactly like
the Android SensorEvent
and sensor classes.
So the SensorEvent in Android
has accuracy, the sensor
information, the timestamp,
and the values.
We basically did
the same thing.
So on the receiver side, it
essentially looks like you're
getting a sensor event.
Instead of actually an Android
sensor event, that's going to
be a data-sharing
library event.
And then you actually can wire
that into your user interface,
pretty much like you would with
a normal sensor event.
Like I said, this Data Sharing
Library, it's actually going
out relatively soon, if
it's not out already.
I didn't check my email in
the last couple of hours.
But it's going out at
code.google.com/
p/googletv-data-sharing.
The link will be on the Google
TV developer's documentation.
And the two samples that I
showed you a moment ago,
they're also both on there as
well, so you can actually run
those out of the code
repository.
Take them, extend them, do
whatever you want with them.
They're pretty much your
guys' to play with.
So that's actually sharing any
data between a second screen
and a first screen device
or Google TV.
And now I'll talk a little bit
about Anymote, which is a
little different paradigm.
So the Anymote protocol is
actually what we use for the
Google TV Android remote control
and the iOS remote
control that are available
for Google TV now.
So basically, the idea is that
you turn your handheld device
into a remote control for
sending key events, touch and
mouse events, and
Android intents.
And we'll talk a little bit
more about how that works.
Dave's example really
kind of captures the
benefit of all these.
But so Anymote in itself,
though, is a protocol or a
specification that defines how
apps can actually securely
send these types of events from
a second screen device to
a first screen device on
a user's home network.
Every Google TV device has the
Anymote service running, so
you don't have to worry about
implementing anything on the
Google TV side, like you did
with the sensor information or
the Data Sharing Library.
So Anymote, actually,
the service is
running on Google TV.
You're just responsible
for what goes on the
second screen device.
And the interesting thing about
the Anymote protocol,
the way it works on Google TV,
is that whichever app is in
the foreground actually receives
the Anymote events.
So basically, if you're familiar
with the Android
remote control, I can use that
for navigating pretty much
anything on the device, or
actually controlling any
application on the device.
And this is actually really
unique in the Android world,
because generally, applications
cannot send key
events or touch events to
another application.
So this allows you to actually
build an application on the
second screen that will actually
send these key events
and touch events to another
application on
the Google TV device.
So again, this is a
client/server infrastructure,
so the second screen
is the client.
The first screen
is the server.
Discovery is also via mDNS.
That's the point of the mDNS
Anymote protocol that we're
broadcasting.
The pairing protocol,
since it is secure--
and the reason for security is
since you're sending mouse
events, and you're sending
touch events, and you're
sending intents from the second
screen to the first
screen, you don't want just
anybody sending that data
across your network and
controlling your TV without
some kind of authentication
and pairing process.
The other thing is, too, is
that if you're using your
handheld device and you're
sending key events, you don't
want other people on your
network, necessarily, sniffing
those key events.
Because you could be entering
a password or sending
confidential information from
your second screen to your
first screen.
So there's an authentication
and pairing dance they
basically involves the second
screen sending a request to
Google TV, saying hey,
I want to pair.
The Google TV displays
a challenge to
the user on the screen.
The user enters the challenge
into the second screen device.
The pairing happens.
And then actually, Google TV
sends back a TLS certificate
that the first screen
device can use for
encrypting the message.
And then from that point on,
once you have the certificate,
you use it for just sending
your events.
I'm going to give you another
quick demo, just to show you
how the parent process works.
If you have the Google TV
Android remote control, you've
probably seen this before.
But it's a pretty
straightforward process from a
user's perspective.
Make sure I'm on all the
appropriate networks.
I unfortunately can't show the
auto-pairing, just because I'm
not using a standard network.
So I'm actually going to cancel
on the auto-pairing.
I'm going to do a manual
pairing, which means that--
oops, I have to get
out of this demo.
DAVE FISHER: Do you want me
to bring it up for you?
PAUL SAXMAN: Yes, please.
Another cool thing about this
technology is that you can
have any number of devices
connected to your TV.
So actually, Dave is bringing up
all this information using
his laptop, which he
will talk about.
DAVE FISHER: Don't look.
This is what I'm going
to talk about.
PAUL SAXMAN: All right.
So I'm going to do
a manual pairing.
Like I said, the manual pairing
generally isn't
required on a user's
home network.
It's just because we're in
kind of a funky network
configuration here.
But this is really the discovery
process, where I'm
actually finding the devices
on the network.
I'm going to go ahead
and connect.
And then this is the pairing
process itself.
I'm sorry, I actually am kind
of in the front there.
So the handheld device has
actually sent the command to
say, I want to pair.
Google TV actually displays
this to the user.
I got a really easy
one this time.
I enter that in the phone, I
hit my pairing, and then
everything's done.
The user is paired
to the device.
So now when I actually use this
device here to actually
navigate around, that's
actually sent across
to the Google TV.
I can go back.
I can go home.
Pretty much, in the Google TV
Android remote control, we
have pretty much everything
for keyboard
input, touch events.
All the Android keys, et cetera,
are all captured on
the device.
Anybody implementing this can
actually send all the same
events across as well.
So that's pretty much
it for that.
So if we go back to slides--
So as I said, Anymote
is a specification.
If you want to learn about how
Anymote works, you can
actually go to our developer
site for TV remote.
It talks about the
specification.
And there's actually quite a
few libraries out there and
open source codes.
Discovery is generally handled
by the second screen
application itself.
That's not baked
into a library.
But you can use something
like JmDNS.
Pairing and authentication--
we have a reference
implementation in Java that
works on Android, and there's
also a C++ implementation that
we released very recently.
And for sending events, you
actually use the Anymote
protocol reference
implementation, which is also
Java and C++-based
applications.
The libraries both use protocol
buffers, the same way
the sensor demo did.
Here's all the URLs.
The important thing about this,
though, so there's a lot
of things that you'd have to
do to actually get started.
We recognized this.
This code we actually launched
last year, the reference
implementations.
But there's still kind
of a high barrier
to implement that.
So what we did very recently, as
well, is we made the Google
TV Anymote Library for Android
developers, which works really
similar to the other
implementation
that I showed you.
Basically, the major steps
is you implement the
ClientListener, you open up the
service connection, you
bind to the
AnymoteClientService, you
start sending events.
I'm just going to kind of speed
through this a little
bit so Dave has enough time
to give his demo.
So the code is very
similar to before.
You create an activity.
You implement the
ClientListener.
This time you have three
methods to implement.
The most important one,
obviously, though, is the
onConnected, where you actually
get an AnymoteSender.
That's the class that you use
for sending the events.
Same as before, you have a
service connection so you know
when the Anymote service
has started.
And that point is when you
actually pass your
ClientListener to the service
so that you can
receive those callbacks.
Then you're responsible for
actually starting an intent.
You can do that on your
onCreate method.
You can do that whenever
you want, basically.
You can have a pairing button
in your application.
It's up to you.
And for sending events,
basically what you get is you
use this AnymoteSender to send
things like key presses.
This one, I think,
is really cool.
By the way, this is actually the
Android key events, so you
just tell it what Android key
event you received, and you
can pass that along.
The TouchHandler is actually
a really cool class.
Basically, you pass it any view,
and it turns that view
into a touch surface.
So I can use it to send
touch events across
to the Google TV.
You can send intents.
And this is actually
a really powerful
feature of the protocol.
It allows you to start up
applications or actually go to
URLs, so you can send view
intents for loading up Chrome,
for example, or going to
the Android market.
You can start applications, like
the YouTube application,
and tune it to a particular
video.
Or you can do things like start
your own application.
So if you've gone through the
pairing process and you have
an application on Google TV that
you want to control, you
can send that intent, bring your
own application up on the
device, and then start sending
the input events across.
Like I said, this library
is also open source.
It's also available for
you guys to use.
Hopefully you saw really
simplifies how Anymote works.
We have another sample
with that.
We have another sample with
the Anymote library for
playing Blackjack.
Pretty simple, but you guys
are free to take it
and run with it.
And with that, I'm going
to pass it on to Dave.
DAVE FISHER: Cool.
PAUL SAXMAN: Thank you, Dave.
DAVE FISHER: Four
minutes, huh?
Nah.
Twenty minutes.
All right, so what I'm excited
about, Paul's been telling you
about how you can use phones,
how you can use tablets.
My world is about the
laptop, right?
So this actually fits me
really well as a user.
I'm sitting there, I'm watching
TV, I've almost
always got my laptop out.
Maybe that's not a good thing,
but that's how it is, right?
So I'm talk to you
about Anymote.
That's the communication
mechanism, communication from
your laptop.
And we're going to do it
via Chrome extensions.
So first off, just to kind of
make sure we're all on the
same page, Chrome extensions.
Who here has made a Chrome
extension before?
All right, like 10 of us, all
right, I raised my hand.
How many people have used a
Chrome extension before?
All right, excellent.
So I know what my audience is.
You're not really Chrome
extension developers.
Hopefully this'll be
your first one.
So just a little background
on what they are.
You can download them from
the Chrome web store.
They add functionality
to Chrome.
There's a great developer site
where you can you learn more
about making them.
A couple things they can do--
they can be browser actions.
A browser action is basically
like a small icon.
So these little icons up here
are browser actions, which is
a little separate program.
Or they can be content scripts,
which add things to
the page you're looking at.
So there's two things I want
to talk about today, one
user-facing and one
developer-facing.
First, we're working on
a Chrome extension for
communication.
Not out or available yet.
We're still working on it, kind
of brainstorming ideas.
I asked if I give a demo today,
and they said, go nuts.
So what this extension
does id I've already
paired with this TV.
So I did the pairing code that
Paul showed just a second ago.
It's using Anymote.
I can send key events.
So if I wanted to send the
search command, you can see
that the search box
will open up.
If I hit the Back button, if
I hit the Home button--
it's got all the functionality
that a remote
does with the buttons.
It's also using your keyboard,
which is really nice.
So the arrow keys are probably
the most useful things.
All of Google TV is D-pad
navigable, so the
arrow keys are huge.
You can also type.
So if I say, Hello.
Well, I can't type.
But I could type,
if I knew how.
So those are kind of the
basic keypress events
that you can do.
But since it lives in Chrome, it
actually travels along with
you as you surf the web.
So in this example, I'm
on a Google+ page.
If I'm looking at things
on this Google+ page--
here I got sent a link
to some funny site.
You decide if it's
funny or not.
And what I could do is, if I
wanted to share with the other
people that are in the room with
me what I just found, I
can actually fling
things to the TV.
What it's actually doing is it's
sending an intent that
opens up a web page, which opens
up Chrome on the TV.
In addition to being able to use
your keyboard and to send
these special keys, you can
also use your mouse.
So you've got access to your
keyboard and mouse, which I
think is really nice.
Other things it can do-- go
back to the Google+ page.
We can look at a page, and we
can say, is there anything on
here that they might want
to have on their TV.
So here's a YouTube video.
So the best screen in your house
is probably your TV.
So what we do is we look at the
page, and we say, is there
anything on this page that a
user would be interested in
having on their TV?
And we give you links to make
those things quicker.
So here we found this YouTube
video on our page.
When we send it to the
TV, it just plays.
You can share it with
anybody in the room,
which is kind of neat.
It actually works
wherever you go.
So here, we've got YouTube
videos in a Gmail.
You can see that it's
found those, and I
can send those over.
Didn't want to stop with just
YouTube videos, though.
We actually wanted to make
this kind of like it's a
companion that travels
along with you as you
surf the web, right?
That you can send things
to the TV.
So here if you're looking at a
page that's related to a TV or
movie entity, what we can do is
we can say, we found some
TV programs on this site.
And if you would like, you can
actually send those over to
the TV as well.
It's going to open up the
TV and Movies app.
And then from the TV and Movies
app, you can do things
like you can save it to your
queue if you think you want to
watch it later.
Or if you want to watch it
now, you can see what
options there are.
If you had Netflix, it would
show up in this list.
Things like that.
So that's the extension that
we're playing with.
So what we're doing is great.
And in making this tool, we're
going to open-source some
things so that you
can do your own.
So really, what the
developer-facing announcement
is about is how can you make
your own extension.
So we're going to show you the
tools that you can use.
But first, why?
Why would you want to do this?
I've broken it up into
a few categories.
Maybe you're a web developer,
and you want to get your
content to Google TV easier.
Maybe you're an Android
developer.
How many Android developers
do we have?
All right.
That's my audience.
That's what I thought.
And you want to talk to your
Android app, this is a way you
can make a customer
remote control.
Or maybe you just have
some other idea.
So I mean, if you're a web
developer, you can make things
that you can fling.
If you're an Android developer,
you can make a
custom remote or something that
goes with your app, so
it's kind of like a partner to
where you can play with your
Chrome extension as well.
Or if you have just some other
idea, there's all kinds of
things you could do.
Your computer knows
a lot, right?
And it can share this
information with your TV.
So how?
How do you make this happen?
We've got a code.google.com
project that
you should go visit.
It's just called
google-tv-chrome-extensions.
There's an example in there for
how you go ahead and do
this pairing and
communication.
But there's actually
one more thing.
So I said I'm a college
professor.
I couldn't resist the
opportunity to give you a
homework assignment.
So you've all been assigned a
homework assignment, and that
is the AnymoteLearningExercise.
So the idea is you'll learn
how to use this Anymote
communication.
And so there are
two extensions.
One is the example,
which is finished.
And then the other is the
learning exercise, which is
missing all the most important
pieces, right?
So it's the same extension, but
it's missing everything
that's useful.
And we've broken it up into a
couple of different exercises
to make it easier for you to
learn, just kind of go
through each step.
Let's take a quick look
at the example.
So in the example here, what
I've got is it's another
browser action.
What I'm going to do is I'm
going to create a plug-in,
which I'll talk about more in
a little bit, that's kind of
initializing this
communication.
Things you can do with Anymote,
is you can find TVs
on the network.
Here we've used discovery.
We found this TV.
I've listed by IP address.
We show you how to begin the
pairing process, so you can
see a pairing code
popped up here.
So dbe1.
And so now I'm paired
to this TV.
You pair one time, right?
So if you use an extension every
day for a month, you
pair once at the start of the
month, or forever, and that's
the one and only time you're
going to need to pair.
And then to actually
communicate, you open an
Anymote session.
Anymote, you would have to
open every day, right?
So every day, you would start
up a new Anymote session.
This would do the
communication.
And we've got examples in here
for how you can send keys,
like the Home key,
the Search key.
How you can send data, so here I
send the data "Hello World,"
just because it's kind
of a Hello World app.
How you can do YouTube flings,
which would be opening up the
YouTube app.
I should define the
word fling.
Fling really just means to
send an Android intent.
It doesn't mean Chrome.
It just means to send
an Android intent.
So here I did open Chrome, but
you could open YouTube.
You could open the TV player.
Really powerful.
And then the last one
here is ping.
This is just to test the health
of the connection.
So that's the solution.
And these are the steps that
you kind of went through in
the solution.
I should show you the starting
point as well.
Way less exciting.
So the starting point, if you
click on any button, it just
says, I'm not implemented, so
that's what you should do.
Not nearly as exciting.
Extensions are made up of basic
web components, HTML,
CSS, JavaScript.
So you can see here that
we've got an HTML file.
This is the HTML that's going
to get loaded if you click
that button.
So it's really like a local
bookmark, is another way to
think about it.
Some CSS, some JavaScript.
Then the other thing that
extensions have
is a manifest file.
You're Android developers, so
you know the manifest file.
And extensions, it's JSON
instead of XML.
Same idea, though.
You're configuring, hey, what
does this application do?
So in this manifest file, I'm
saying things like, I'm a
browser action, so that's
why I've got the icon.
When you click me, you
open this popup.html.
The other really important thing
is that this extension
uses a plug-in.
So depending on your platform,
it's going to load an
appropriate plug-in.
And it'll choose this based
on your system.
You don't have to
worry about it.
So really, there's
one plug-in.
It will just pick
the right one.
When we first realized we were
going to have to use a plug-in
because Anymote requires
level security with SSL
communication, we were initially
bummed, because we'd
rather stick with the
web technologies.
But if turned out really
nice for developers.
So we were forced to make a
really well-encapsulated
module that's really
easy to use.
So that's what we're
giving you today.
So really, this learning
exercise, it's all about how
do you use the plug-in, right?
So that's the main thing.
And it's ready to go.
You can just steal it,
and you can use it.
So really, using
this plug-in--
so this plug-in comes down
to 20 functions.
So if you can call these 20
functions, you can do
everything that you
need to do.
Paul--
[LAUGHS]
DAVE FISHER: Awesome.
Paul talked a lot about network
communication, things like this.
That's really exciting stuff.
You should learn how to do it,
but you don't have to.
So this makes it really
easy for you.
And so we're going to use these
20 functions that are in
the plug-ins to implement
these buttons.
That's what the learning
exercise is all about, right?
We're not going to go
through all of the
learning exercise today.
I'd hate to steal your fun.
We're just going to show you
one of the steps so you can
see how the flow works, right?
This is going to increase the
likelihood of number of people
that are doing it.
It just went from
10% to like 15%.
So we're going to show
you one button, the
initialization button.
What needs to happen in
initialization is you need to
get this plug-in, which was
written in C++ and compiled,
accessible in JavaScript.
So that's kind of
the first step.
And then once you make it
accessible in JavaScript,
you're going to make three
clients, for discovery,
pairing, and Anymote.
So it's a really natural
breakdown.
We'll go through the code
extremely quickly.
So right now, that button
just says, hey, I'm not
implemented.
What you're going to have to do
to implement it is you're
going to have to create
an embed--
this is kind of our bridge--
of a certain type.
So you add that to the DOM.
The embed, by the way, we've
actually made visible.
So when you click on this
initialize button, the embed
is this white square.
So that is the embed.
Usually you don't make them
visible, but we did for
learning purposes.
And then you've got an embed
element which essentially is
the plug-in.
You've got one crazy function
to call on it.
That crazy function brings
you into JavaScript-land.
So pretty simple.
Kind of a crazy method name,
but pretty simple.
Then you need to initialize.
So the initialization step,
there's an init, and then the
main thing that happens in
initialization is your
certificates.
Your certificate is how you're
identified to the TV.
Once you're paired, it's that
certificate which says, hey, I
trust this device.
It's used for encryption.
Some boilerplate
stuff in here.
You don't have to worry
about the details.
But once you've got that
certificate made, and once
you're paired, you want to hang
on to that certificate.
And then initialization
is ready to go.
So you make these
three clients,
discovery, pairing, Anymote.
Say it a couple times there.
So we're going to stop with the
exercise here, but that's
kind of the first step.
If you were to do discovery,
pairing, and Anymote, there
are some API functions for
discovery, to start the
pairing process, to send the
response, to start the Anymote
session, and to stop it.
And then the most important
slide is, once you're
connected, what can you send?
What can you tell the TV?
Key events, obvious.
Mouse events, which
I showed you.
Mouse wheel events,
for scrolling.
You can actually send arbitrary
data types.
Right now that means
sending a string.
That's how I did the
Hello World thing.
Fling, I'll step over once.
Ping is just to test
the health.
Without a doubt, my favorite is
definitely send fling, right?
Just because if you think about
how Android works, how
communication in Android works,
I mean, if you can send
an intent somewhere, you
can do a lot, right?
And this gives us the ability
to send intents.
All kinds of intents
you can send.
I showed you the code here for
flinging the page that you're
currently on.
Probably more fun than that
though, is if you wanted to
fling YouTube, you can send a
URI that will open YouTube
specifically.
If you wanted to open the TV
player, you could send this.
You could actually send
parameters, like channel and
things like that, on
the TV player.
If you had an app that you
wanted people to download on
the TV, you could send a link to
Market to open up your app.
So it's like, hey, download
the other half
of this tool, right?
So that one, I think, is
useful for people.
And then it's kind of crazy, but
you're passing a string.
But you can send almost
any intent.
You can send extras, URIs.
You can set the category.
It is kind of a crazy
string format.
There's a function
called toUri.
Which creates a string if you're
on an Android platform.
And really, what the receiving
end does is it calls parseUri.
So you can send anything
you want.
You just have to know how
to format the string.
I've got some advice for
how you do that in a
doc that I've made.
But if you were developing your
own app, you would know
your package name, right?
You would know the names
of the activities
that you want to launch.
And you can explicitly
call those things,
which is really great.
So these are the 20 functions
that you have to learn to use
this thing.
I wanted to definitely give
credit to Dave Hawkey.
He's my 20% hero.
He wrote the C++ code that
all this is built on.
He also open-sourced all the C++
code, which is really good
if you're C++ developer.
It's all out there, everything
that he used to make.
C++ works on a lot
of platforms.
I'd love to see somebody run
with it with iOS or to do
their own thing with
the C++ code.
And then your next step is to
go out there and do the
learning exercise.
Anybody going to do it?
All right, show of hands.
Come on.
Everyone in the room just
raised their hand.
This is great!
So that's all we've got.
Thank you for coming.
[APPLAUSE]